بعد ثلاثة أشهر من
الميمات والتهديدات ،
يمكن أن ينتهي الأمر بملحمة المسك على تويتر في
محكمة ديلاوير ، ترفض دعوى تويتر تمامًا
ادعاءات المسك بأن الشركة
فشلت في الكشف عن المبلغ الحقيقي
للحسابات المزيفة وروبوتات البريد العشوائي على
المنصة وتتهمها  انسحابه
من الصفقة لأن السهم قد
انخفض بشكل حاد منذ
الإعلان عن الصفقة وهو الآن أقل بنسبة 30 في المائة على
الأقل من سعر عرضه بشكل جيد ،
تريد الشركة إجباره على الوفاء
بالتزاماته التعاقدية
والتمسك بالعرض البالغ 44 مليار.  لقد
استجاب لطلبنا للتعليق ،
لكنه نشر تغريدة من سطر واحد ، يا للسخرية ،
لكن المفارقة هنا هي أن تغريدات المسك
هي في الواقع مركزية في حالة تويتر ،
تفاصيل الإيداع عدة تغريدات من
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة تسلا تقول إنها انتهكته.
الالتزامات التعاقدية بعدم
الاستخفاف بالشركة علنًا وحتى استخدام هذه
التغريدة من يوم الإثنين لاتهامه بعدم
النية مطلقًا في التحرك نحو
الاندماج و  بدلاً من ذلك ، باستخدام الموقف برمته
لإجبار تويتر على الكشف عن
المعلومات في المحكمة جيدًا ، فإن خلاصة
القول هي أنه مع وجود أكثر من مجرد
تساؤل الآن عن حجم مشكلة روبوت البريد العشوائي ،
فإن تويتر يريد توضيح ذلك
في أسرع وقت ممكن ، فقد قدم
طلبًا للإسراع  الإجراءات وعقد
محاكمة لمدة أربعة أيام في سبتمبر ، والتي من
الناحية النظرية تترك بعض الوقت
للجانبين للتفاوض على
سعر بيع جديد وتجنب معركة قانونية باهظة الثمن والتي
قد تكون ضارة
كريس سيباستيان cnn london